welcome everyone to the panel that I
think must must be part of a conference
on Pakistan in Bangladesh to reiterate
when we organized this conference veena
akbar and I wanted it to be about
Bangladesh and Pakistan specifically
Bangladesh and Pakistan recognizing of
course is I think nanika said that India
might well be the set of elephant in the
room that one has to dance around them
when we set this panel up the debate
about secularism should we say broadly
speaking in India had reached a
particular or has reached a particular
kind of stalemate there are dogmatic
positions on both sides Pro secularist
anti secularists certainly leading
scholars have declared this secularism
in India is failed it is inapplicable
and that in fact nothing more needs to
be said about it what we could all agree
about was that however it was that one
thought of the secular as concept
secularism as ideology secularization as
process all of it was centrally
concerned with the lives and the bodies
primarily of women and so we decided
that we must have a panel on feminism
and secularism Africa of Bangladesh and
Pakistan needless to say the debate
about feminism and secularism as it did
in India but since we're not talking
about India I will henceforth speak only
about Bangladesh and Pakistan brought up
the ubiquitous question of religion or
the twin of secularism and in this panel
all three scholars will address the
different issues raised for them through
their examination of the practice and
theory practice and theory of feminists
of feminism secularism and Islam
however differently all three of them
understand all three terms in as
capacious a fashion as possible in both
the activist and the academic millions
activists can't be academics academics
can't be activists or at least there is
a kind of tension between them we
recognize that
and we're gonna try and do the four of
us Afiya Amina Dina and I we're going to
try at least to do something which we've
posed as a challenge to ourselves which
is to have a panel of four feminists and
have them agree to disagree so we'll
find out if we can be successful we're
going to go in a particular order I'm
going to start with Dina Siddiqui and
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
her as soon as I can find a bio Dina
Siddiqui is visiting associate professor
in the Women and Gender Studies program
at Hunter College she's a cultural
anthropologist with a strong interest in
gender human rights and transnational
feminist politics and particular
expertise and gender in Islam in
Bangladesh she took her PhD in
anthropology from the University of
Michigan and other her research and
publications concerned globalization and
human rights non-state dispute
resolution systems and the cultural
politics of Islam she's been a visiting
professor at the Center for gender
sexuality and hiv/aids School of Public
Health
BRAC hakka senior research associate at
the Alice Paul's Center for the Study of
women gender and sexuality at the
University of Pennsylvania and a
research fellow at the Center for Policy
dialogue in Dhaka she's part of the core
advisory group of the South Asian
network of gender activists and trainers
Sangha and a member of the Coalition for
sexual and bodily rights in Muslim
societies last year Dina and I taught a
course we taught a course on gender and
the politics of feminism in India
Pakistan and Bangladesh they generated a
lively debate and I can see some of our
students in this room so we hope you
will all contribute to the subsequent
debate and it's a great pleasure to
invite Dina to be the first speaker
thank you very much John Oakey and I'm
really excited as I was saying to you
the other day about having this
opportunity to talk about Pakistan and
Bangladesh and have this conversation
that really is so rare I'm going to
first I'm going to begin with a set of
caveats
in some ways address some of the
questions that all of the panelists got
and then I want to hopefully I'll have
time to talk about my work with I've
tried to connect it with my work with
Bangladesh legal aid services and Trust
which I was encouraged to do because
thanks to sorry I was saying our keynote
speaker and I really want to thank her
for linking me with that so and I I will
say one of the biggest differences I was
thinking today between talking about
women in Pakistan and Bangladesh is that
there's a real geopolitical difference
because finally there simply isn't that
important and for that I'm quite happy
geopolitically we don't have to worry
about drones we don't have to worry
about u.s. foreign policy and and I
think that really does locate the
analysis of women in a particular way so
that's where it that's that's that's the
first thing I want to begin with the
some caveats about what I argue about
and what I don't argue because I don't
want to be misheard or have my words of
misappropriated now most of what I say
in this section on caveat is going to
sound very familiar from a much
rehearsed script and at this point kind
of trite polemical whatever you want to
say but please bear with me because I
think these things the fact that I feel
that these things need to be rehearsed
and repeated as part of my point about
not just about who speaks and whose boy
who is allowed to speak but what kinds
of voices are heard and through what
kind of pre-existing sort of narrative
some you know some speech the meaning of
some kinds of speech is always over
determined by other things so it seems
like whenever so therefore I have to I
have to spend time on this so I want to
say I am NOT interested in defending
apologizing or explaining Islam I don't
study religion I'm not interested in
Muslim practices increased public piety
political Islam and the like and if you
get that sense from a from my argument
then I will have failed to convey what I
want to say I am NOT a Muslim
feminists which I've been called to
indulging in identity politics but I do
refuse to authenticate my secular
credentials by claiming to be an atheist
or a communist or whatever the
antithesis of being Muslim is I argue
here and elsewhere and I've done this
for a lot and a lot of my work has been
look has looked at the discourse around
fatwas and how that discourse travels
and then comes back to Bangladesh I
don't I am NOT supporting fatwa or
flogging obviously but I argued that the
Disciplinary powers that shape women's
lives in Bangladesh should not be
reduced to the oppression of religion so
whether we're talking about faith was
issued in village tribunals or forced
marriages and it's not only because this
kind of framing feeds into stereotypes
about Islam and patriarchal barbarity
but I four more importantly for my
purposes it forecloses closer attention
to the ways in which to the
intersectional and multi-layered
workings of power so that if you take
away Islam you don't necessarily you
take away you ban fatwas you don't
necessarily get rid of you know you get
rid of one strand of oppression but I
can see it might work you know that that
you know there is a lot left the call
for attention I think basically it
undermines the possibility of effective
activist intervention so the call for
attention to context it's not simply
about greater accuracy or detail
nor is it to refuse political or moral
judgment it is to attend to as Lyla
loo-loo got in her unpacking of honor
crimes shows what's the easy deployment
of categories such as Sharia or honor
crimes prevents us from seeing about the
social and political world in which
violence against women is occurring far
as Mary John reminds us excuse me
context is not simply about extra
information context is constitutive of
meaning so the meaning that we derive
depends on sort of the how we
contextualize particular acts we can't
take these cultural acts
you know vlogging whatever else out of
their context and this is not an excuse
for it's why I'm always told that I'm
excusing and defending Islam by in in
odd and audiences at different points in
different places have said that to me so
this is not the same as saying we cannot
critique Islam or that Islam is not
patriarchal and harsh and barbaric in
many forms so my argument why is it then
that my argument is heard as apology or
defense or cultural relativism or much
worse as a dangerous inadvertent cover
for the political actions of the
religious right I find it a little
baffling but I think in Bangladesh it
has a lot to do with the very tainted
history of Islam and nationalism and
I'll come back to that that was the
first point the second point is I am NOT
pitting imperialism against feminism or
secularism the argument is not that
everything always has to be related to
imperialism however given the
appropriation of the language of liberal
feminism in the service of a decidedly
anti-feminist imperialist agenda I don't
see how we can escape an interrogation
of the politics of knowledge production
around the vexed category of Muslim
women at least with those of us writing
in English producing knowledge for a
global english-speaking audience on a
post-colonial and eminently
transnational site such as Bangladesh I
think this at least calls for heightened
vigilance if nothing else of how our
work is appropriated in and so I'm not
saying that we can't describe ground
realities I'm saying the tools with
which we have to describe those
realities already come saturated with I
don't know he said somewhere you know
with with with colonial histories and
imperial presence you know they're just
they're they're you know this is what we
these are the frameworks that we have
and third I am NOT against secularism I
don't think it's a term we need to just
get away from although I do think that
feminists have to strike a broader net
than only secularism because the way at
least its ex
in Bangladesh it can be very
exclusionary and if the are 'kathy
debates in Bangladesh are always about
the nature of Bengali nationalism and
it's about Bengali Muslims and Hindus
basically it's a very it's a very
nationalist debate it's it doesn't talk
about anybody who is either not Bengali
speaking or not Bengali and who in do
basically are Muslim so you know you
leave out for instance you leave out all
the ethnic group people in nature the
gong he'll touch the atiba she's they're
all left out of the discourse if this is
the only discourse we focus on as
feminists then and if feminism is about
producing social justice I think we have
a little bit of a problem and again I'm
not saying that you know I am NOT
arguing against secularism so I'm not
getting into those Indian debates here
I don't treat secularism as a trans
historical category or a static
condition that can be achieved rather I
would say that secularism that is as it
is mobilized in Bangladesh needs to be
historicized in relation to the
development of Bengali Muslim
nationalism and I think because of the
specific conditions of the emergence of
Bangladeshi nationalism in explicit
opposition to Islamic culture
quote-unquote as the sanctioned
narrative goes policing the lines
between secularism in Islam is
frequently presented in the idiom of
loyalty to or betrayal to the nation
consequently saving women from
fundamentalism can be conflated with
saving the nation the result is a deeply
problematic understanding of secularism
as being the opposite of or of not Islam
and a subsequent disengagement with
Islam as a precondition for secular
politics this is for something that
feminists have had a lot of problems
with and I think the kind of how to
engage with forms of piety that women in
Bangladesh are taking on and the kind of
hardening of identities that's happening
is something that we can't ignore or
simply just say you know we need more
secularism we have to sort of rethink
the grounds on which we talk about
secularism
I would say and it's not a debate that's
been had in Bangladesh and I think it is
an important debate to have and if this
sum this outcome of understanding
secularism namely a retreat from
religious subjectivity is somewhat
analogous to the situation in India
where as Anupam ro has argued caste
amnesia has been seen as a precondition
of being secular and modern and has led
to what she calls the rise of
Brahmanical feminism the refusal to
engage religion in the name of
secularism therefore as in you know it
lights an interrogation of the
intersecting structures of domination
especially inequalities along axis of
class in Bangladesh okay so so that was
my third caveat but I think a lot of
what we do a lot of the times people who
have my line of argument is constantly
sort of you know keep rehearsing these
caveats the call to reframe debates on
secularism feminism and nationalism and
I think I do I would argue to get beyond
the secularism religious binary I think
um there's a kind of liberal rash
feminists need to engage with ways of
being human that sort of outside of
liberal feminists rationality it's very
difficult but as actually a young
graduate student at Columbia my amock -
she puts it
you can't rationally disabuse people of
their beliefs religious arguments
mobilize aspects of being human that a
secular liberal rationalist cannot
simply discount and I think that's a
huge thing right now for feminists to
engage with this is not the same as
silencing or censoring those who want to
critique Islam or valey those who think
veiling is oppressive whatever in the
same way critiquing US policies on
drones should not prevent us from taking
a stand against religious extremism and
I would like to argue that one kind of
analysis should not for clothes the
other indeed I want to turn to the
charge that the subject of Muslim woman
has produced a new kind of political
correctness in
Academy in particular that we cannot
protect Islam anymore in the way that we
can press Chianti or Judaism or animism
or
you know Hinduism but of course there is
no corresponding use of these other
religions you know there are no global
discourses of saving Hindu women or you
know saving Christian women but the
question reflects a political reality in
which a person's take on Islam and
gender has come to index their politics
which itself has become a function is a
function of the political and symbolic
burden on Islam I would say though that
criticizing Islam has become an act of
moral courage as Pankaj Mishra pointed
out somewhere and in fact we shouldn't
forget that the voices that get the most
institutional and popular support are in
fact the likes of ayaan Hirsi Ali and
Ishod Monty and I totally agree that
Hirsi Ali is free well within her rights
to say that Muslims are programmed to
kill infidels mutilate females that the
West has no choice but to stamp out
barbaric Islam she's free to call on
Muslims to convert to Christianity to me
what is instructive is the amount of
serious intellectual and institutional
attention that people like Monte and Ali
receive and how the mildest of
criticisms and it can unquote in Pankaj
Mishra here from the likes of Ian burrow
McCann elicits a tsunami of vitriol from
her army of prominent supporters this is
that there's a larger power structure in
which all of this is happening in which
people like me and and I'm locating
myself in the u.s. here but my thrust of
my analysis it really isn't it you know
which limits not just what we say but
how we are heard and it's the how we are
heard it's that flattening that I would
like to argue against so I want to flag
two issues why is it that calls for
complexity and context reality are
systematically misheard after all the
claim is not that we shouldn't criticize
anything about Islam because it's under
assault but to understand how these
conditions of assault then mediate our
understanding and framing of what the
problem is
secondly what are the consequences of
speaking a bit of not being heard are
not really making a dent in this larger
hegemonic discourse the calls for
specific calls for specificity in
contextualization the insistence that
people's lives be understood within
political economic and historical
context are not so different from
earlier critiques by Chandra Mohan te
Iowa on and others on the production of
a third world female other always you
know who is different culturally but
always in need of salvation I mean in an
old-fashioned kind of way you could see
these calls to be about the dangers of
binaries if you wanted to of white men
saving you know if in the old days it
was white men saving brown women from
brown men it's now white and brown men
sitting Muslim women from their men and
their cultures so what you end up in the
end having is again a shift away from
politics which is and inequality toward
essentialized sexual and moral
differences I find that the kind of
critique I offer is both anticipated and
summarily dismissed as the standard
polemical blaming of the u.s. or appeal
to cultural relativism or hidden
sympathy for the jamaat-e-islami which
is why sadly i felt like i had to offer
these caveats i am off the opinion and
please feel free to disagree with me
that feminists have to agree to disagree
on certain things
if the debates over feminism and
secularism are at an impasse perhaps
this is a good time to move on not try
and solve those debates perhaps you know
i think the question of feminism in
relation to imperialism in islam in
particular has produced many
unproductive fractures and cycles and
accusation and I think as famine as a as
a South Asian feminists like that's um
well it's it's a it's a very hard a
place to be now I just found out I have
five minutes and this really wasn't I
really what I really wanted to talk
about is this in credit but was not this
but this is going to take just two
minute five minutes of my 15 minutes but
I have five minutes though I did I did I
did I did maybe I won't I can't actually
make the transition in any case but I do
want to say and I've done some research
for Bangladesh legal aid services trust
on looking at how cases of suppose it
rape are actually turned out to the
cases of women who consensually have
cases of breach Beach promises of how
women are basically having sexual
relationships and the men leave and
don't marry them when it once the woman
gets pregnant so it's you know the
relationship is allowed it's a very
familiar South Asian scene and so I was
looking at the conflation are not the
conflation I suppose a slight between
consent and rape and that idea of rape
as part as a breach of promise being
considered rape is not something that's
related necessarily to any religious law
or if although it is it's there to
assert but it's not quite it's not just
about Islamic laws of zina or local
ideas it's very much within their sort
of older colonial law of breach of
promise that's where you know in laws of
seduction and people use this deploy the
law women deploy the law in order to
further their own interests I was
actually going to talk about it and
while I was doing a you know research on
this and trying to relate it to this
panel and what I realized is a you know
I was finding how much these cases
internationally and inside Bangladesh
are generally related as woman punished
for being raped and it really fits into
this idea of oh my god there are those
Muslims go again it's a very complex
thing one the main point of my thing on
sexuality my thing on concern
and a seduction and rape laws is that we
don't when we focus either on religion
or whatever else we actually we
foreclose questions of sexuality which I
think are much more difficult for us to
ask because we know because what we are
saying is you know we that in a sense it
asks us to confront female sexual agency
of very young girls right here are these
people you know who have sex who get
caught until they get caught all
everything is allowed but once they are
caught they're you know it's a different
scenario and I do think that the
politics of sexuality gets completely
overlooked in the in the sort of in the
attention only to the rape and the
punishments and I do want to say these
are things that of course we absolutely
have to make sure you know the very
harsh punishments that are there are
stopped but in a sense of just the it's
a very it's a more complicate the
analysis has to be more complicated than
that okay thank you thank you you know
we have enough time then after panelists
so if you want to return and speak a
little more about the research that
you're doing we can certainly work that
into the discussion section move now to
Amina Jamal our second panelist who is
assistant professor in the department of
sociology at Ryerson University in
Toronto Amina Jamal took her PhD in
sociology from the University of Toronto
and her research highlights the new
types of citizen subjects who I'm urging
from the complex interplay of gender
race religion and sexuality with
changing global economic political and
cultural relations she's presently
engaged in a three-year study entitled
in and against the Islam / secular
dichotomy particularly appropriate for
our panel South Asian Muslim women's
struggles and transnational feminist
practices funded by the social sciences
and Humanities Research Council of
Canada
Ameena Thank You Janicki I also want to
thank the organizers Johnny key and a
bird and of course Deena and I need to
thank
Deena twice because she has already
contextualized the dangers and
difficulties of speaking as a Muslim
woman about Islam and secularism so I
don't need to do that I'm not really
going to be talking about my present
work because I think one of the
configure button the dilemmas was
because we were given these set of
questions to talk about Islam feminism
and Islamism and secularism we didn't
know we wanted to respond to all those
questions and I am one of those people
who got caught up in that and tried to
respond to all those questions rather
than focus on my current work but this
is also connected so with the expansion
of the war on terror and increasing
Islamophobia in Western societies and
I'm situating myself both in Canada and
in Pakistan feminist movements
everywhere face intense pressure to
defend their struggles for universalize
notions of freedom and human rights and
I think that is part of what we
understand as the feminist movement in
Canada or at least the mainstream
meanwhile as Islamist movements make
deeper inroads into social and political
lives in muslim-majority States feminist
movements in these societies rely
increasingly on the promises of
secularism
and their struggles for the elusive
project of civil society I'll explain
what I mean by secularism and Islamism
later on if you ask me a question the
resulting cultural political
contestation so between these Islamism
and secularism are commonly framed as a
conflict of Islam versus secular and
this framing tends to overwhelm National
Assembly debate Street process media and
media programs in states such as
Pakistan and Bangladesh repeat what is
of really of concern to me today is
that replicating the discursive
boundaries of the dominant debate
feminist representational practices and
politics in these societies and within
Muslim women's groups in Canada for
instance and the US have begun to
diverge exclusively to diverge towards
exclusionary secular and political
religious forms and indeed in Pakistan
even the mainstream feminist movement is
split between those feminists who seek
to invoke Islamic scriptures in support
of women's rights and those who advocate
the traditional Muslim secular position
of insisting on the strict separation of
religion and politics in this paper I
argued that the framing of feminist
projects and implicitly women's rights
as secular or religious not only
obfuscates our understanding of the
complex experiences of the vast majority
of Muslim women but has the potential to
undermine the emancipatory claims of
many movements for the rights of women
religious minorities and other
marginalized communities in Muslim
majority states such as Pakistan and
Bangladesh
I suggest that notions of both women's
secularism and women's Islamism in South
Asia need to be deconstructed and
problematized
as historical processes of gendering
there are also practices of power thus I
propose that a feminist debate about
secularism or Islam needs to be promised
on the following understanding
continuing legacies of imperialism in
the modernization and development
projects of nation-states combined with
new forms of capitalism and patriarchy
have shaped the context for different
kinds of politically gendered subjects
in those spaces of the world that are
described as belonging to the Muslim
world or to the Islamic world these
emerge in the contemporary space of
public politics as to dichotomous
subjectivities
on the one hand there is a historical
constituency of Muslim women who
articulate the demands in the language
of human universal human rights and the
fundamental rights of citizenship and
these women define their struggle as
secular on the other hand an
increasingly visible group
Muslim women challenges the conventional
narratives of political development and
rejects the idea that religion should
retreat into the sphere of the private
as societies become modern and these
women are often referred to as religious
or Islamic and so what I won't go if
this is of course along the paper and a
longer research so what I want to do is
just try to to my way of approaching
this dichotomy is to try to trace what
is the space of the Muslim secular
because here we are talking about not
secularism or the secular as a
decontextualized project that you know
many scholars have done very remarkably
well but I just want to see what it is
is it who inhabits the space of the
secular
in a Muslim society like Pakistan or a
Muslim like like myself I identify
myself as a Muslim feminist unlike you
know we will discuss that later
so what is the space of the Muslim
secular and here I want to just talk
about that a little I feel that there is
no doubt that the experience of u.s.
imperialism and colonialism have tainted
the notion of secularism and intensified
the underlying tensions in Muslim
societies between feminism and
fundamentalisms also among different
groups of Muslims between Muslims and
other religious minorities between
heterosexual and homosexual between Shia
and Sunni and so on indeed many
Pakistani scholars including myself have
attempted to describe explain and
analyze the present conditions in
Pakistani society and I would point here
that I I believe I would try to argue
maybe not successfully but that it's not
simply 2000 September 2001 that we
should look back to for the history of
this secular religious dichotomy in the
case of Pakistan we look should look
back to 1970 this 77 and onwards and I
mean the first Afghan war and General
Zia Hawks coming to power and his
project of Islamization of state society
and
and of course also the rise of the Saudi
oil wealth and its regime of promoting a
particular brand of Islam so I feel that
is a much more of a key moment in
understanding feminism and seculars in
Pakistan then as well as 2001 but much
more than so not going to go into the
details of this history because I'm sure
many of you are familiar with it but I
would argue that secularism as a
discourse and as an idea is inextricably
entangled in this history and it's
representational politics so but even if
we were to think about so having said
that even if we were to think about
secularism without the region's recent
geopolitical context it is untenable to
suggest that secularism is necessarily
Cohen joined sorry that secularism as a
political and cultural project anyway is
a disinterested project the question of
secularism is necessarily Cohen joined
with the question about the seemingly
inevitable illusion of secularism with
human freedom and so an intellectually
decontextualize discussion of secularism
inevitably begs the question raised by
post-colonial and post-structuralist or
whether there may be other ways of being
free and human and I'm not and you know
referring to you for instance Talal
Assad's work and dr. Spivak work as well
to some extent these authors argue that
the secular function some especially
Talal Asad and Saba Mahmood have argued
that the secular functions in state
building discourses to D legitimize and
oppress all modes of being a living
outside its secular framework and from a
different location of engaged with some
of these contradictions earlier of
secularism as a feminist Human Rights
Project and I've also attempted to
theorize why Muslim feminists based in
South Asia who are otherwise critical of
the colonial and appending underpinnings
of the secular modern are to the dismay
of they come
Patriots in first world academic context
often unwilling or unable to abandon the
possibilities and impossibilities
attached to the idea of secularism and
so in an earlier paper have suggested
that we read the seemingly uncritical
invocations of the secular by Muslim
feminists in Pakistan as a rhetorical
strategy and I've tried to theorize it
by using dr. Spivak snow ssin of cata
crisis or the the strategic misuse of a
concept that has no empirical referent
and which opens up a space for
transformative practices so having sort
of I think talked about the Muslim
secular I want to turn to the space of
the Muslim religious which I think also
is a new space which is you know come
into being in Pakistan and I would argue
that in most in its and it is related to
secularism again in its in more recent
invocations both secularism secularism
both as a process of State and society
formation and the secular as a form of
identity construction have been
appropriated by many levels of Muslim
society including feminism as a
potential force to counter another
formidable discourse Islamic modernism
and it's related vision of state
formation which is theorized as Islamic
so in my own study and my work on
jamaat-e-islami women in Pakistan it
became evident that Jamaat women's
attempts to achieve the Islamization of
women's status is in fact through the
state and thus it is a historically
specific mode of engagement with the
modernist discourses of individual
rights and national community so it was
as much a mod project of becoming modern
citizens as a mode as much as a project
of becoming good Muslim women so what
I'm arguing is that a genealogical study
is needed of what is deemed to be the
Islamic discursive tradition in a
particular society at a given time in
order to understand the violent ruptures
as well as the continuities of the
social formation I argue that Islamists
are not need to be theorized as part of
modernity rather than as part of another
tradition that is outside of modernity
so in I'm not so what I want to
highlight is the multiple modes of being
religious or secular may articulate with
the conditions of nation-state politics
in many contradictory ways
so like any political struggle within
Pakistan the secular religious dichotomy
needs to be understood in the context of
the nation-states colonial and
postcolonial history its geopolitical
location
I mean Pakistan's geopolitical location
in the regional and global conflicts in
South West Asia the lasting cleavages
and people's social realities affected
by colonial and imperial cultural
maneuvering the role of local and global
neoliberal policies in shaping
Pakistan's economic weaknesses and the
rapacious tendencies of the our
country's military and civil leaders and
cultural elites so I think these are all
shaped by these so women's defining of
themselves of others as secular or
religious are all shaped by being
attentive to the these discourses and so
I have debates about secular and
religious implicate much deeper and
wider class and gendered processes of
subject formation and long-standing
matters related to struggles over
authority construction in the region and
I mean also religious authority
construction so to further illustrate my
arguments are examine the stories of
three women in Pakistan who despite
incommensurable divides of class
nationality ethnicity and religion
became linked in a new discourse of
terrorism and human rights enabled by
the war on terror in ways that confound
feminist debates about secular and
religious the multiply located and
contentious discourses that frame the
accounts of the experiences within the
nation-state of pakistan demonstrated a
logic of an authority that i submit not
only challenge the base
of secularism but also unsettled the
Islamic societies given relationship of
faith and disbelief Zod and Cooper in
other words so three women that I'm
talking about and I can give you more
details later is Martin mine who was a
poor rural woman who was gang raped in
2002 Aafia Siddiqui a Pakistani American
citizen of Pakistani origin who's
serving a life sentence in a US prison
after being sentenced to 86 years in
prison for firing at a US soldier in
Afghanistan and then the third woman is
hacia Bibi also named hacia Noreen a 45
year old Christian Pakistani woman who
was who's facing a death sentence for
allegedly making derogatory remarks
about the Prophet prophet Oh Mohamed I'm
not a concerned here with arguing but
what was the truth or falsity of the
details of each case but I'm just going
to you know just talking about how these
stories were represented so an entry
point was that in late 20 2010 national
international media began to publicize
the case of hacia BB a Christian woman
who was going to be hanged you know for
committing blasphemy and of course some
of you know that this really escalated
with the political religious party is
really demanding that us a baby should
be killed and you know the it led to the
the murder of Salman Darcys the Governor
of Punjab and also Pakistan's only you
know religious minority representative
che basmati and so on shop shortly after
words the protests became even more
complicated with the issue of Raymond
Davis again an American who had shot a
Pakistani two Pakistani men in what he
said was self-defense
and of course the drama ended with the
earth being a blood money being paid to
the retribution being paid to the heirs
of the - you thought he shot the
situation grew to encompass doctor and
my as it was around this period that the
Supreme Court issued its decision
regarding the six men accused of a
gangrene and not going to talk about all
the different media that have looked at
but what I will say is that the three
women who experienced different forms of
violence emanating from a convoluted
nexus of State Society community became
fused together at the number of
discursive registers these different
discourses clearly such that support for
Mukhtar Amaya SIA Bibi was deemed to
imply a move against Islam and in
support of Western liberalism in
contrast the recovery of Asiya Aafia
Siddiqui became represented as a
religious obligation and a matter of
national standing while McDonough in
Ostia Bibi poor rural women were cast
out as unrepresentative and unworthy of
national sympathy
Arceus Aditi a mill across Pakistani
doctor bearing American citizenship was
unequivocally embraced as a daughter of
the nation
so the ideological and so we what we
find is that liberal feminists support
in Pakistan for Aafia Siddiqui was muted
by suspicions about the ill liberal and
religious basis of her project which is
was a mineral opposite of the Islamist
right wing position which refused
victimhood - poor Pakistani women and
continues to refuse if their situation
hints at any links with liberal and
westernized progressives and I have to
add with this disturbed this
representational dividing line of
secular and Islamic was disturbingly
ashed along the contours of what many of
us know as the Bordeaux medium and
English medium cultural
in our society and you know which
becomes most evident through the the
print media one of the few spaces that
have opened up in Pakistan for elite and
non elite or the medium English media
and everybody to come together is the
new independent channels that have
proliferated thanks to the neoliberal
you know opening up the state and so I
won't I can't talk about it but here I
do talk about a particular show called
capital talk in which the host Hamid
Mead has earned a reputation as a
strident critic of what he terms liberal
fascism in Pakistan I reference mostly
to feminists and human rights groups and
NGOs and in one discussion that I
discussed here the hammock need and
others were really engaged in debate
with Farzana Bari who arguably may be
said to occupy the secular space in
Pakistan and true so there were you know
through contingent events and discursive
projects of subject construction and
victim Constitution
Mukhtar mi and RC abhi be as I said were
represented almost as intransigent
feminists who were manipulating local
national and international forces and
institutions to further their interests
Afiya V be a fierce Aditi became the
quintessential victim of Islamophobia
and feminist secularism violence against
women discursive Lee constructed and
circulated through selectively
appropriated ideas about nation religion
Islam and the West that meant that
Mokhtar my hacia Bibi and obviously
Utley could not acquire the
substitutability required to become
unconditional human rights victims nor
could they become equal members of a
global community of women based on
experiences of gendered violence what is
important to highlight here is that the
read secular religious framing of the
issue undermined the conceptual
coherence and political rigour of both
feminism and Islamism
so by muting their support for our fear
Siddiqui feminists may have beacon the
Lib weaken liberal feminism's own claims
about gender as
the basis for women's identity and for
organizing politics
similarly political religious Islamic
groups in refusing to recognize the
violence again Mokhtar Belmokhtar in
mine and hacia be be rendered specious
their pronouncements about Islam's moral
ethical universalism and I'm just going
to end soon but I just want to say that
on the conventional sort of political
front the divisive discourse erased the
important intervention of those
religious subjects who in a rare
instance of this kind challenged the
intent and authority of political
religious parties in defining what is
Islamic and what is an Islamic so Anu a
few notable ulema as such as Java the
McCarthy and Khalid Hassan who tend to
avoid direct involvement and religio
politics in Pakistan came forward to
present very strong and brave arguments
to weaken the claims of the leaders of
political religious parties in spite of
their public statements there was no
meaningful realignment even a temporary
one of the proscribed notions of
religious versus secular and I'm just
going to end here with by pointing out
that we need to formulate a language for
the and put an put the secular that
unhinges it from untidy association with
Islam is aversive framing for South
Asian Muslim women struggles against
those structures that we consider as a
brace oppressive and constraining of
their social worlds
we turn now to the last speaker who is
off here Sharon Asya I love your name I
just
Sharon Asya thank you Afiya Sharon Asya
was there like her name so much I will
say all of it and not just Alfia is a
feminist activist and independent
scholar she's an active member of
women's action forum participates in
pro-democracy activism in Pakistan and
has worked in the non-governmental
sector I'm sorry that should be and has
worked in the non-governmental sector on
women and development Afiya writes
regular columns for newspapers is a
commentator on socio-political issues on
several television channels she's a
founding member of an academic study
group in Karachi and her current
research focuses on the challenges to
secular feminism in Pakistan secular
feminism is a given in afiya's work as
the women's movement confronts growing
conservatism and Islamic militancy both
of which are also Givens in her work so
we hope for a lively debate
she is contributed to scholarly journals
and as the author of sex crime in the
Islamic context rape class and gender in
Pakistan published in 1994 she's also
edited a series of books on women's
issues including locating the self
perspectives on women and multiple
identities in 1994 and unveiling the
issues Pakistani women's perspectives on
social political and ideological issues
Alfia cher bono Zia
Thank You Janaki thank you and the
organizers for inviting me to this
conference I'm very honored
anyone who knows dr. Mirza he will agree
that he maintains a very high standard
of academic expectations both of himself
and of others so to be nominated by him
to be on this panel is a huge compliment
in itself Thank You Akbar I guess I
would also begin my paper with some
disclosure apparently due to my
political affiliation and personal
research interest on secular feminism in
Pakistan I seem to have acquired the
reputation of being a hardcore secular
feminist but this is neither inaccurate
in sentiment nor a source of personal
anxiety but it seems to trouble a
growing number of scholars who argue
against the teleological assumptions of
secularism and for increasing the
recognition and space for religions
particularly Islam in public spaces and
political expressions now apart from the
fact that hardcore secular feminist
makes one sound very much like an anti
men Antichrist porn star or born artist
because where else is the term hardcore
used so deliberately except in the porn
industry apart from that it is a
revealing statement however about the
increasing polarization and
fragmentation of feminist identities in
Pakistan it also encapsulate s' the
evolving differences between feminist
thinking's in muslim-majority societies
and their diasporic counterparts so
these are the two themes of competing
feminist identities that my paper will
attempt to address today with reference
to the broader debates over secular and
religious politics important not just
for feminists but also political
activists in general in Pakistan and a
word on Pakistan now the Pakistani state
is perhaps a post structuralist dream
come true it baptized itself as the
Islamic Republic as a political
afterthought de facto it's neither in
Islamic state nor a secular state it's a
weak state in terms of political
democracy and social services but
brutally strong militarily the colonial
justice system it inherited is
juxtaposed by an Islamic legal system
but the most efficient
is the thriving and parallel
extra-judicial one in the form of
community-based tribunal justice to
observe the veil in Pakistan is an
elective right for women there is no
legal enforcement nor prescription from
observing it mainstream and Islamic
banking are equally exploitative women's
legal testimony is half that to men's
under Islamic law but women can and do
serve as judges
I don't think currently in the higher
courts Islamic punishments are not
executed by the state but Islamic
justice or Nizam a other has been
legislated for the tribal areas of one
province of Pakistan and so they have
the right to do so
a post-colonial post structuralist
postmodern utopia if ever there was one
which may just explain that despite not
being a Middle Eastern country something
that American commentators regularly
forget Pakistan still seems to be a
royal mess however this mess does not
don't Pakistanis as much as it causes
anxiety to the rest of the world mess is
fine if citizens of Pakistan are allowed
to wade through the mess themselves and
allowed to contest out our internal
identity politics by ourselves and for
ourselves and at the risk of sounding
protectionist this would mean not just
resisting political and economic
interventions but also academic ones so
what have been the recent political and
academic verdicts about Pakistan and
Pakistani women's identities in
particular the narrative of Pakistani
women's rights until the mid 1990s was
premised on a universalist
transnational and transformation
feminism global and regional sisterhood
was always discussed and debate it
debated in the light of shaping it
seeping it within local specificity and
relevance and just when this project got
interesting around the time of the
Beijing World Conference in 1995 and of
course always with contestation things
got derailed somewhat and this may be
attributed to two main factors the first
and less relevant one is with reference
to Western politics whereby some
feminists from the Laura Bush School of
feminism after the events of 9/11
supported the moral imperative for a
liberationist project that envisioned
the freeing of Muslim women in
Afghanistan and indeed all around the
Muslim
world a second development far more
relevant and at first glance could be
mistaken as perhaps even indigenous to
Muslim context is that Islamic feminist
politics in various contexts began to
gather momentum and they call themselves
Islamic feminists they often represent
and symbolize resistance of criticism of
both patriarchal interpretations of
Islam and/or Muslim men who obstruct
what are considered islamically
appropriated appropriate women's rights
the Islamic feminist project has over
the years become appealing for several
Western governments and these projects
are often very well funded and supported
by international development agencies
which kind of kills the romance of
indigenous evolutionism right here and
in defense of secular feminism in Muslim
context it may be pointed out that if
international funding qualifies as the
source of suspicion over the agendas and
relevance of any school of feminist
activism then this suspicion must now be
equally extended to Islamic feminism or
other Piratas movements or faith-based
projects and research that receive
support from predominantly
anglo-american but also Arab funding
sources then wedged in between these
ideological constructs or Western and
Islamic feminist concerns there are the
native secular feminists who had been
contesting a very local political pre
September 2001 struggle against routine
patriarchal abuse of power religion and
social inequalities very much a part of
the broader issues of women's identity
politics were Islamist women who
categorically deny being feminists these
non feminist Islamist women along with
the relatively more recent quietest
Muslim women's movements have become the
subjects of much diasporic scholarly
interest post 9/11 and one can
accurately put a date to this interest
the scholarship is interested in
recovering Islamist or Piatt 'test
women's agency interiorized subjectivity
and their relationship with modernity in
varying degrees however what this
scholarship refuses to do is to look at
their politics and one understands
academia is impatience with the pros
big field of politics one also
recognizes the growing interest in
anthropology and ethnographic studies of
Islamist agency modernity even the
allure of dissonance within Islamist
movements and this allows for very
interesting insights however the
political proposals emerging from such
research often remain unchallenged and
unquestioned it's not enough to call for
a redefinition of Islamic fundamentalism
or redesign academic categorization or
point out the odd act of dissonance
while ignoring the risk the risky
political consequences of such endeavors
and the reason for this is that personal
faith-based agency often does not stop
by academic conclusions - instead more
often than not these convert one day
into political activism it would be
simplistic to list or critique the
comparative achievements of secular
versus Islamist women's rights activism
in Pakistan were still it would set up
false binaries but it would be helpful
to contrast the approaches methodologies
and results of their campaigns without
talking about achievements which are
modest for Pakistani women according to
any index one historical contrast of
political attitudes towards nationalism
and religion in Pakistan may be founded
in the responses to the war of 1971 when
Bangladesh became independent from West
Pakistan over 15 years ago as mentioned
this morning the secular feminists under
a forum for women's rights groups
women's action forum have been the only
ones to have demanded a public apology
from the Pakistani State for military
atrocities committed in 71 war of
independence and particularly for the
rape of countless Bangladeshi women as
part of war crimes no other groups
individuals perhaps personal narratives
perhaps no other group from amongst the
moderates certainly not right-wing
ideologues and not even paya 'test
subcultural groups have ever taken such
a position even privately and this was
not a paper campaign or stunt staged by
secular feminists painful introspective
debates reflected on conflicting
nationalist and feminist identities and
this is an important point because for
secular feminists the independence of
Bangladesh exemplifies the tenuous bond
that Islam held
between these two countries in the face
of the compelling colonial attitude of
West Pakistan on the other hand women in
Islamist political parties as well as
piety movements refused to accept this
failure of religion to serve as a public
or political bond they deny even today
on record that Bangladesh is really
wanted a separate homeland now this to
me is a significant and personally
disappointing counterexample or what
homi Bhabha calls the time lag in
post-colonial modernity in this case the
time lag has not allowed for a
renegotiated present not even a new
narrative but in fact has allowed a
conscious erasure
of the historical at servitude that East
Pakistan was subjected to and the
Islamist and pious women on record
choose to sit on the lids of the memory
holes of history the three high kana
graphic cases cited by Amina while
high-profile and media worthy are not as
I see it as representative of the
religious secular divide as the more
routine examples of rights based and
collective movements in the country are
just over the last decade the most
significant ones have been entirely
spontaneous and secular including the
nationwide sustained lawyers movement
led by ethicists in here the nationwide
lady health workers movement begun by a
single rural woman peasants and fisher
folk movements and the movement against
enforced disappearances initiated and
sustained for 14 years by a woman from
Balochistan by secular I am simply
referring to the fact that there have
been absolutely no religious undertones
motivations recourse no impulse from
religious sentiment nor have these
campaigns used religious props nor
support from piety and neither have they
been informed by religious debate
they've also been largely successful in
achieving their purported aims or at
least in gaining legitimacy and
recognition of their demands the most
successful rights-based movements by
Islamists during the same time period
have been to retain the religion column
in passports and the one that prevented
the reform of the discriminatory
blasphemy law
the question then is how much more deep
privatization of religion is needed when
it's already so deeply entrenched and
invested in state institutions and
public discourse I have to confess that
Spivak is not quoted much in Pakistan
not ever actually but she makes an
interesting observation when she
suggests it was not benevolent
colonialism that first motivated
northern feminist negotiations with
non-western cultures rather she
suggested it was more appropriate to say
that Western feminists were propelled by
ignorant goodwill instead the current
proposal by diasporic Pakistani
academics writing on Muslim women's
identities such as Saba Mahmood Asma
Burley's the unlikely cameraon hustler
himera at the DAR and others who are
located in the West but would not
identify themselves as Western that's
just a label reserved for liberal
feminists who actually live and politic
in Pakistan many of them do not claim to
be feminists either what is proposed by
them as they attempt to rescue the
agency of the subaltern eyes Muslim
woman I'm suggesting is not motivated by
benevolent colonialism of course nor
ignorant goodwill certainly but instead
in varying degrees a mixture of all four
conditions a kind of benevolent neo
colonialism that is certainly not
anthropologically ignorant but such
scholarship chooses to be politically
ignorant it also lends Goodwyn because
this idea of rescuing the agency of
Islamists excites many international
bureaucracies who are keen in Obama
esque manner to repair the damage of
relations between Muslim countries and
the West and who can use them the
communitarian logic of religion as an
entry point for much of their
development projects in Muslim majority
countries so yes a combination of
benevolent colonialism and ignorant
goodwill could be said to be the
foundation impetus of the recent
diasporic scholarship on Muslim women's
religious identities to lend them
scholarly credibility several
international funding agencies have
employed semi academic ethnographers and
Muslim scholars who have recorded ad
nauseam Anna's
it is a totally new post-911 phenomenon
that Islamist groups actually perform
organize charitable work in the field
and should be therefore eligible for
international funding support what I
described elsewhere as donor driven
Islam so Saba Mahmood allegations that
think tanks such as RAND Corporation
actively campaigned to promote the
theologically dent agenda of the United
States is accurate except it's not us
imperialist Christianity as she suspects
it instead it's this thing called
moderate Islam yes we can provided we
fund the right brand of Islam now most
Pakistani feminists do not agonize over
diasporic commentary even if it is over
the question of Muslim woman's
relationship with religion they are not
staying up all night to read the defense
of secular feminism either except that
the nature of our location necessitates
an engagement between and amongst local
feminist perspectives precisely because
this engagement is political not just
academic the anti secularists and the
postmodern critics of the Enlightenment
thesis and of liberalism who used to be
called just plain conservatives but I
understand it's all about the new ends
now they insist they insist that the
state must accommodate religious
politics but they refuse to engage with
the various consequential products of
religious modernity or vehicle concern
is that the of equal concern is the fact
that the theocratic state does not
tolerate secular resistance and in the
case of Pakistan at best vacillates this
is a good sign it vacillates precisely
because the tension between the
religious and secular do exist
legitimately so to dismiss Pakistani
society as overwhelmingly religious and
therefore impervious to secular
alternatives is to seal out the
transformative possibilities offered by
non faith-based politics all this for a
bit to make Islamic relief and I refer
both to the organization and the
metaphor to make Islamic relief more
palatable than say red cross and to sell
that as a logical response to the
apparently alternative needs of all
Muslims everywhere secular feminists
call
for expanding the spaces that are
created through a political not
metaphysical secular resistance to
religious fundamentalism and patriarchal
politics whatever the Western historical
relationship may have been the
confluence of Western and secularism
refuses to recognize that the secular
domain in Pakistan exists despite the
lack of secular institutions and
therefore it has its own definition
vision and symbolism it's not Western
it's not Indian and it's not according
to a new proposal Islamist and sometimes
maybe it does resonate with these models
in the same way socialism did briefly
before it was concertedly wiped out by a
u.s. sponsored Islamist resurgence in
our region but it is undeniably and
historically of a differently secular
but non theocratic variety the very
material analysis offered by secular
feminists may be unsexy but it is an
accurate documentation of the nexus of
cultural and religious patriarchy's
their analysis goes beyond the reading
of the subjectivity of Islamist women
and it Integra gates their political
activism as in the case of the religious
vigilantism practiced by the jamia hafsa
women or the nationalist patriarchal
discrimination observed by the pious
women of al-huda it's not just
inaccurate but also apolitical to ignore
the past and potential contributions of
secularism while flirting with the
spectacle and performativity of Islamist
women in Pakistan the concern is also
that such projects often imply that
secular women are somehow detached from
their own reality to conclude let me
just said when non militant
fundamentalists and Islamists including
women non militant fundamentalists and
Islamists attack non-governmental
organizations forcibly prevent women's
marathons shut down shrines and women's
shelters even remove female mannequins
from shop windows the would-be Pakistani
secular state retreats momentarily and
then resumed services Andrea points a
fresh batch of women employees in the
same threatened shelter and even the
mannequins go back up in store windows
that's our nebulous secular resistance
and the task of secular feminists is to
oppose any heteronomous politics
including those produced
colonial post-colonial imperialist and
non new Imperial adventures they do not
however aspire to some political
imaginary where it is presumed that if
the Western form of mannequins were
replaced with veiled Islamic versions
then maybe that would be a more
befitting or effective means to address
women's rights and representation in
muslim-majority societies therefore the
appeal is that feminist politics in
Pakistan should not be pushed into that
false direction by either political or
academic interventions which are
propelled by the notional rather than
the substantive thank you so I fear I
feel like saying to you don't hold back
tell us how you really feel before I
turn it over to questions I think
because veena began with caveats that
took up a lot of time I want to you know
it's not even you weren't able to speak
of your research yes okay
the floor is open to questions as you
can tell obviously the politics of the
political positions by each one of our
panelists is different on my left my
extreme left is the idea that there are
other ways of understanding what it
means to be human what it means to be
woman what it means to be free that the
discourse of secularism simply cannot
accommodate and I mean now you're
somewhere in between but on my right is
certainly a fear saying that there are a
range of non faith-based political
activities by women in Pakistan that
have not received anywhere close to the
kind of scholarly attention in the West
primarily in large part because faith
based politics are seen as shall we say
the new crucible out of which should
emerge a new understanding of precisely
the kind of human subject that Dena is
speaking of in between we have
nah who is the only one of our three
panelists to speak of a Muslim secular
space and a Muslim religious space Deena
would not and nor davia but Amina wanted
to push both the notion that there is a
space that in fact in contradiction to
both of the other speakers can be
considered a Muslim secular space and a
Muslim religious space yes
my job is moderator is not to talk any
more than that but simply to open the
floor for questions with the requests
please pose your questions as a question
and if you're going to make a comment
do please keep it short yes take names
awkward you think we can just move the
mic around a little make it easier for
people to speak it's detachable go ahead
go ahead I'm sure we can you know Anika
you had no Alan yeah you had a question
no Anika after Agana no Amica and then
Jamal well the mind is dead let me see
yes we can speak up just stand up and
speak up
you see
wait wait are you saying that this is
sort of non-canonical expression that
has a greater possibility okay okay um
you know do you want to take the
question of how Muslims secularism okay
yeah it is you know obvious that I'm
coming from that particular background
so I am situated in what is called this
label of Sufism but of course in you
know in South Asia we didn't really we
use the word Sufi but it's a it's a much
wider a different kind of tradition for
theory it's also you can call it shrine
based their multiple ways of talking but
it's all under this label of Sufism and
I don't mean that intellectual kind of
Sufism which is a very Middle Eastern
kind of thing people sit around and
hulka's and all but I do feel that that
spirit of it so for instance someone who
would personify what I mean by the
Islamic secular again it was you know
the word secular was not used by Muslim
so to define themselves it was
progressive Russian really and those
kind of things but that's what I mean by
the Muslim secular so a person I would
say who would for me exemplify that is
abul kalam azad for instance maulana
abul kalam azad then here in fact i had
a part of my paper was a quote from his
essay called sermon the martyr and in
1910 he wrote that in asia politics has
always operated and the guise of
religion and thousands of murders
committed for political ends have been
hidden under religions cloak now I'm not
saying that he's saying Islam is a
terror
religion but what he this particular
essay really looks at the relationship
between dara shikoh who was a much more
heterogeneous what you might call a
multicultural Islam is a Sufi oriented
has come a contrast with Oren's Abe and
of course the Irish akua's we airings
Abe had your honor
Oren's Abe's rule Salma the martyr was
killed and all that so yes I feel that
that not Sufism in this kind of
institutionalized manner that we have
now that is being promoted and you know
and in the West and all over but yes for
a long time we have had that tradition
in South Asia so when in my current
project and I'm going to end very
quickly when I'm interviewing people
that's the sense that I'm getting people
don't want to say I'm an atheist I'm
secular I don't believe in religion many
of the sexes secular feminists that I've
spoken to say that that's that's what
this mean by by you know secularism in
Islam they don't mean the kind of
secular project or the secular that for
instance illallah Saba Mahmood or David
Scott and others have conceptualized and
theorized in their work they are they
mean the secular in that kind of way
there's no other known no language the
other language that is given by the the
mullahs which is linear which is also
not the understanding very quickly in
answer to your in response to your
question I would say it doesn't I are
used to suggesting that there's the
Sufis Ahmad bowels are a better version
of religion but you know because in that
sense because then I would say no
because I mean it that's just not a good
enough approach because then you're
assuming there's something you know if
you could get a happier friendlier you
know version of Islam and the problem
would be solved I really think you're
not then locating the problem the way
I'm seeing it as sort of intersecting
interlocking in which religion is only
one strand of power especially when it
comes to women we
domination is with class you know it's
not just religion so you know can you
have a happy Sufi Yale so big so what
however kind of Sufi you have I do want
to and I and I think related to that I
think what's missing what I didn't say
and I should have said and I will take
this moment is to say that what is what
I find problematic in mind that I really
couldn't care less about women who want
to wear the hijab or do whatever and I'm
not interested in rescuing their agency
I'm not interested in them at all as
long as an eye you know quite tippy as
long as they are not pushing their
religion on me but what I think is very
sad in a Bangladesh and other places is
that we've lost the battle of there's no
left anymore so we've lost a certain
kind of battle that Islamists have taken
over they've hijacked the language of
equality and rights in a way that you
know it's Bangladesh is this you know
super neoliberal state and what does
that mean it means the kinds of
vocabularies that we have available are
also very limited so the only people
sadly who are talking about critiquing
imperialism happened to be the
jamaat-e-islami and their ilk and their
critique is not the same critique that I
would like to make and I don't want to
be conflated with them but when I do
make a critique of imperialism because
the videos is talking about it it gets
read in a particular kind of way and I
think this complete elimination of left
politics is is is something that we as
feminists need to consider the other
thing is that I really actually would
like to reject this idea that somehow
that location is only about geography
I think location is political and
ideological and the politics of location
has a lot more to do with simply living
in one place I do know people in viola
ditch who would agree with me not very
many but I don't think it's just because
and they face the dangers of and there
are very real dangers in Bangladesh you
know of religious extremism but I don't
think one gets a monopoly in
authenticity by being in one place as
opposed to another one intervenes in
kinds of ways if there are different
kinds of interventions and I would never
say I have the full truth to anything
but I do have partial interventions and
partial readings that I think are very
very you know critical Amina and then if
we get aminos response then we'll take
three questions just very quickly the
same response to this notion of Sufism
it has been launched as an alternative
in fact I think USA it is proposing to
set up a Sufi University in Pakistan so
they got there before you did okay but
the same response really how does
something that is seeks to be non
institutional now you institutionalize
it and then hope that it'll be less
patriarchal than the other brands that's
an issue the other quick response is
that you know this idea that feminists
or activists have a problem with
secularism I mean I would debate that I
think they have a problem with men not
necessarily just with with the ideology
of its secularism in that sense and also
that you know if the right has you know
what is loosely called the right has
taken over the debate of of
anti-imperial or taken over the position
of anti-imperialism then they've done so
by their own force and by the power that
they have managed to accrue and it is a
failure on the part of the left it has
nothing to do with you know because
we've created that vacuum therefore the
right has come in the right is coming
because that was their gender always and
so they've taken up more of that space
and how you respond to that I think and
how you critique imperialism that in
that case I think location does become
important it's not just what you're
supporting but what you're critiquing
and and how you approach that criticism
that the question of location Location
ality does come up in that process
no Anika then Jamal and then Zahra
Tomas
I understand because to say that there's
that it's not the bad Islam it's a good
Islam you know like the Sufism is the
good Islam because it's tolerant because
it's whatever which by the way is the
monster to be false the the that the
construction of Sufism is this
particularly start always demonstrably
false but the you can't have religious
activism I mean you know typical
secularism and you can't have in this
sense I don't think you can say most
this that a particular kind of
religiosity is a secular religiosity is
something that I just don't understand
because and maybe because I'm just using
I understand secularism and laicism in
in the way they've been used and they
really imply a few several different
things in all of which there's a there's
a set there's either a separation or an
emptying of power of religious
institutions and religious
significations so just just because one
function can find a good religious
identity which is not doesn't go with
the bad institutions I don't know how
that secular person Sarah and it's
basically I have a question about this
secular domain that you speak up which
is not Western Indian or Islamic so I
guess what I'm getting at is what is its
particular context in which it emerges
and in particular what is its class
politics is if it's just Pakistani then
you spoke of a very nebulous week or
structuralist state this is a wonderful
new concept so what is this class
politics
what is the class politics of this
secular domain and in particular what
are the implications for the kind of
freedoms
if opposes and to whom does it propose
these freedoms so shall we take this
round of questions first yes
yes secular fundamentalism when it's
Christian would anyone like to a few but
I mean I agree with that and I think
what I'm proposing is that actually the
only competition for Christian
imperialism is now this thing called
moderate Islamic imperialism you know I
mean it's hegemonic I'm saying what what
is being proposed now by this idea of
promoting moderate Islam there's not any
less hegemonic than any other form of
imperialism and how do they how have we
come up with this notion how has the
United States thought of this there is a
whole process behind it you know that
came about over the last decade of
including scholars who have come up with
this you know alternative proposition so
the only thing that sort of competes
with Christian imperialism if you want
to put it that way is this thing called
moderate Islam and it's a sort of
promise that it holds for most majority
countries ok can we turn to know any
Kyle's question for the entire panel she
had a question of how you all reacted to
a term called secular fundamentalism yes
and then the second question by Jamal
who wanted to ask you Amina whether tell
me if I'm incorrect in paraphrasing this
whether Muslim secularism was not an
oxymoron yes and so for Jamal then
Muslim and Islamic are the same would
that be fair okay but in regards to the
question that you're posing okay so
that's the second question for you and
then the harris question - Afiya about
class politics in the new secular
politics
I you mean what do I think about the
term secular fundamentalism do I do I as
you've described it you know secular
fundamentalism like market
fundamentalism you know it's um some
people would say it's an oxymoron others
would find it insulting and others would
say let's see I guess I would locate I
mean if we use fundamentalism to me yeah
I mean the people who would embrace it
or people who would even use that term
will always come with a politics that I
think are pretty clear in that sense
don't you think I mean it would be
people who and it's not a term I
particularly use but I suppose I could
but I'm secular fundamentalism would be
about feminists being extremely rigid
about a particular way of you know
viewing what feminist emancipation is
and actually in this context let me just
say I'm not particularly into agency as
I said but I do think we are a little
bit unfair to Saba Mahmood and there is
a real simplification of what Saba
Mahmood work is doing because what I
think she's trying to do is actually
trying to say that there are other ways
of being rather than just trying to
rescue agency for Muslim women because
her challenge is to liberalism as a
whole to liberal feminism she uses most
women in Cairo it's true but there's a
larger question she puts two feminists
to which and it's a it's a much longer
it's a question that feminists have had
all along about can there be other ways
of being women that we can accept and
what is our feminism about I may not
agree with this other kind of being a
woman and a fight and other people don't
have to call themselves feminists but
can we live with that can we live with
other these very radically to us
different and extremely patriarchal and
they are patriarchal and she doesn't
deny that they reproduce structures the
patriarchy she's
even denying that she is saying this is
what the women wanted they're not just
all brainwashed and I think we do need
to remember that so you know she would
certainly this is her secular
fundamentalism would be that we you know
that we don't have to go and rescue
these women she would be arguing against
rescuing any of these women is I think
what she would say so I would say that
secular fundamentalism would be to
understand secularism as a disinterested
project of universal emancipation and I
think feminist scholars often use it to
highlight the underlying assumptions of
secular reform projects as you've said
that they have their own colonial and I
think we do we need to to to to really
develop a thoroughgoing critique of the
second of secularism in the context of
Pakistan in the context of the Muslim
well we haven't really done that I think
that's what I'm I'm not arguing against
whatever we understand but I think we
really don't even know what we
understand by secularism at this point
we need to understand what we mean when
we say secular do we really mean lavinia
I mean we have seen settler ISM in
Turkey we have seen secularism in Iran
at one point we've never had that in
Pakistan from the Pakistan struggle was
under the idea of you know as homeland
for the Muslims so to say I think if the
secular ever existed in Pakistan it was
really in the imagination of a hand tiny
minority of elites and I'll say that not
in my life it didn't exist as you know I
wouldn't say I lived a secular -
Pakistan I went to an English medium
school and all that but my parents said
that pray their prayers my cousin said
that I used to say my prayers that kind
of thing so - and even no no I can't I
don't
I mean I'll have a glass
on it for my pastor sorry but I'll do
all those things but I don't I do also
sometimes say my prayers that I
definitely go to shrines and many of the
times I've had my prayers answered by
them so I can't I mean to say that we
can be secular that way I think really a
handful of people in Pakistan are
secular in that sense that who can
really believe that you can explain
everything by science and reason and not
turn to religion for any explanations or
emotional you're also science and reason
or the will lead us to progress we
Pakistan has never know I think majority
of Pakistan is at least if there was a
secular project
most of us were left out of it and I'm
from what might be called an elite class
right so I don't know about you know the
rest so there is really no such thing as
secularism in my opinion if Pakistan and
has never been we need to know what it
was okay so I want to subscribe by that
definition there's lots of countries and
societies which are not secular anymore
they just drop it off the map of say but
in terms of the term I think one is that
the term secular fundamentals is a
relatively new one in the sense that the
way it's being used now as a sort of an
opposition to the whole notion of
secularism in in one sense it's not that
it doesn't have a history but it was
used differently they have it always had
its critics there's there's no doubt
about that
but I think that this sort of
concentrated sort of redefinition or
what secularism now means is associated
in a sort of a knee-jerk reaction to now
it's also fundamentalist and it's also
sort of oppressive and what used to be
looked at as a tool of perhaps possible
liberation has now been inverted in that
sense and it's a very concerted
deliberate attempt to do so the idea of
lardy Nia actually has been debunked
quite often within within Pakistan as
well people do understand that the
the secularists use it deliberately as a
political entity they are very conscious
of the fact that secularism can and does
mean anything else but the right always
reduces and collapses it to mean anti
America really that's the bottom line
they don't have a problem with
secularism in India
certainly the jamaat-e-islami has no
issue because they would be dead if
there was there would be no
jamaat-e-islami in India if it was not a
secular state by that definition
similarly they don't have a problem with
secular Europe it's really just United
States and and the way they use it in an
interchangeable fashion the fact that
there are two provinces of Pakistan
which are secular in terms of their
routine everyday politics and in terms
of their engagement modes of engagement
and their social relations always seems
to bypass those who conflate secularism
and liberalism those are two very
conservative societies but they are
secular and had been secular prior to
particularly the northwestern Frontier
Province the secular spaces have been
completely taken over in the last decade
by the MMA which was the right wing
party an alliance of riping who who
dominated and then they change the
entire culture in terms of the
institution's political and the social
relations so you know how do we leave
that out and forget about the sort of
where secular societies have been very
conservative and patriarchal in that
sense also so this I you know so this is
the problem that I have with with this
conflation of terms without
interrogating more deeply the specific
societies and not just you know Punjab
and Sindh in that sense the second
question about this idea of how did what
is the secular domain I think that you
know very easy it's probably more
accurate to say that what began began as
a secular resistance to the Islamization
campaign of general xiahou because that
was the state-sponsored Islamization
campaign so this resistance to it became
defined as a secular resistance or a
call for retaining secular spaces in the
public as well as challenging the
increasing Islamization of the security
of the state that it was not a secular
state but the increasing sort of
collapse into a completely
sort of space where there was no
expression no security expressions or
institutions available anymore at the
same time there was a trend to buy
amongst feminists to use Islam
strategically there was always that
debate the debates that you asked about
there were some and the women's movement
often split on this some believe that
you could use Islam strategically to use
it as a language of rights within Islam
and prevent that that absolute collapse
of all women's rights and they thought
they could convince the state and men
that you know if Islam Allah and I think
that fail miserably as well I don't see
and I keep challenging the anti
sequiturs to tell me where it is they
see that though that strategic use of
Islam has enabled empowered or changed
the state structure you know I mean if
they could convince me of that we could
begin the debate okay we have time for
one more round of questions but before I
get to that and I have your names down
Farsi agita the gentleman in the back
I'm sorry I don't know your name and
then Vina but before that Jamal's
question to Amina I don't think she got
a chance to answer because she would
like to answer it yeah you were saying
is Muslim secularism an oxymoron I don't
think so because if you really look at
know I paraphrase compatible what is it
and I would say again that mohani and
all these people what were they talking
about
also in if you look at Islamic really
except for the the time of the Prophet
and the four Khalifa's even at that time
because in the person of the Prophet you
had the political leader and the
religious leader and maybe they call if
I'm not going to I'm not someone was
Islamic history but after that there's
always been that and in fact during this
case you know this recent hacia Beebe
case that's what some of the Olimar said
like Java damn Romney and I'm not a
great you know I'm not just promoting
him or supporter but I think he said as
he said the traditional ulema never
engage in politics they knew their
position
this so there was a separation the
polymer was there only to give advice
and then the leaders like the Mughals
did that they didn't they want the
religious and political was never in one
person so yes they followed that Islamic
law just as we know that so
the secular laws are all Christian basic
Christianity based laws as people have
said so know is informed by morality and
religion and all that in a society we
can change it of course and I'm not
arguing for an Islamic based system but
I'm saying it's possible yes because
religious authority and political
authority has been separate and as you
said in Pakistan do I mean to some
extent under UConn and all that but it's
only this political religious movements
that have developed since the
Brotherhood and that model B and on
these the politicizing of the notion of
an Islamic state has been the undoing
right so we have one more round of
questions and before that round of
questions before that round of questions
if I may many of you may not have been
here this morning and I would like to
announce a very important change to our
program schedule this late afternoon
because I think we're past it the
introduction to our evenings plenary
speaker Saracen will be given by
University professor of the humanities
Gayatri Spivak I'm very pleased and very
grateful I said all this in the morning
guys but you weren't here so I'm
repeating it yes I'm very pleased and
very grateful that Professor Spivak
agreed to participate in the conference
particularly since I gave her about oh I
think 14 hours notice this was my
mistake I assumed that since she was on
leave that she would like many other
professors want not to have anything to
do with academic work I should have
realized as she reminded me that she's
not like every other professor and that
she works harder on leave than she does
when she's not on leave so publicly my
apologies but guys who Spivak agreed
particularly because I think I arm
twisted her into doing it to introduce
Sarah Hussain are
evening plenary speaker we're taking her
away from her own work for an afternoon
and thank you very much for doing this
guys we will reconvene at 4:40 I've
worked it all out so that we have plenty
of time for Amina to have a drink plenty
of time for a PR not to have anything to
drink no because she made it tell us
start telling us really what she starts
to think but I've worked it all out so
let's reconvene at 4:40 and we take the
last round of questions starting with
Fawzia moving to Gaeta the gentleman in
the back and then Vina you will get the
closing question very interesting panel
but very much an instantiation of in
fact the divide that does exist and my
position on this and I'd like to sort of
put it out there and then turn
particular question to apphia is that it
is it is it is about taking sides and I
think this may answer perhaps somebody
else's question about nuances the fact
is that as academics we are trained to
be nuanced about everything but
particularly as dysphoric Pakistani and
an academic but also one very closely
involved with women's rights issues and
battles in Pakistan and so here I would
disagree I would like to say to Javier
please don't put us all on the same same
box because you don't know that we some
of us do in fact take the position that
for Pakistan and for pakistani feminism
it is a battle for the soul of pakistan
i have no problem saying that out in
exactly those terms and i do think that
at this point notwithstanding the
imperial and colonial history of the
term secularism it is indeed time that
we reconsider secularism and critique
Islamism I mean why is it that we have
to critique secularism and not critique
the Islamist discursive you know agendas
that have in fact taken root in
particularly North American academia I I
don't see that happening and I think
it's time that we do that for Afiya the
question really is I would like to know
for example in the
kind of really courageous work that I
think feminists like yourself have been
doing for a long time in Pakistan where
are things like the sexual harassment
bill who has written up those bills and
presented them what is happening with
you know working on blasphemy for
example what is happening with sexual
harassment I mean with domestic violence
because that was tabled a while ago and
have in fact the Islamist feminists or
those who call themselves that whether
they're on our jamaat-e-islami or
whatever you know people following for
Adarsh me etc what has their
contribution been to any of that kind of
work that really seeks to codify laws
for women in Pakistan across classes
thank you actually veena since you're
right next to fuzzier why don't you ask
your question I think so much with your
question I really wanted to say that is
there a feminism which you might call a
disinterested universalism or is that
too
so now nuance that it doesn't seem to
have any meaning I'm not finding
anything to grasp at what is the
feminism that you are talking about
because it becomes so completely shaded
with you know with the non-secular with
actually Islam so that it you know that
you're saying that Islamic feminist is
so different to let's say a Hindu one or
a Christian one or a Jewish one or
whatever that or or as feminists we are
all calling ourselves feminists I said I
know that you are and so is there a
commonality or are we then nuanced by
the fact that you're Muslim
that's what I okay the gentleman at the
back I'm sorry two questions one just
general question in terms of
relationship between secularism and
Christianity I mean they are william
connolly and others have said that
secularism is essentially a version of
christian religiosity so how do we get
away from that and maybe a particular
question to Dina to you in terms talked
about secularism in Bengali nationalism
and it has constructs itself as anti
Islam but do you still think that is
still there is a positive but something
to rescue from that nationalism as
opposed to the other sides of the
politics which is actually constructing
Islamic ideology so could you hand the
mic over to get up there hello well
thank you to the panel and thank you
particularly to Afiya who I think showed
that activists can be academic as well
as activists and political in their
presentations and and I think that
academics can be activists as well I
know many who have you know feminism
wouldn't be what it is without both you
know actually it's also being activists
some of the dichotomies I think a false
I think they are reflecting real debates
and I and I think as Rai said I think
there there was a movement in Pakistan
and many other places to strategically
use Islam and a lot of women who did it
at one point have come out of that but a
lot of people were using that night I'm
thinking women living under Muslim laws
who they they actually deconstructed the
idea of Sharia as monolithic by doing
comparative analyses and the work that
they did which was extremely
sophisticated and activist work has been
singularly misrepresented by numerous
academics including in Columbia Human
Rights departments and so on as cultural
you know value pluralism
which is not what they were
doing they were actually quite gently by
people's own internal analysis of their
laws showing that actually what is in
each national context is seemed to be
god-given and universal as Islamic
Universal Islamic law isn't it's it's
extremely related to national context
and and and that's been misinterpreted
so I think you know actually people
working with Muslim law paradigms not
Islamist paradigms but looking at Muslim
law issues because they were confronted
with Islam a cessation of law actually
did really useful work which is still
going on and many of those for instance
in in a new movement called misawa which
which which is about a feminist Islam so
it's not so much about deconstruction
but about a feminist Nambiar's work with
human rights concepts as well and
theologians like Amina Wadud are very
clear that they can only operate within
a secular context because secularism is
not at least in my understanding anti
religious necessarily it's about the
freedom of religion and as somebody who
is classified as a secular
fundamentalist and has regularly you
know being attacked and libeled for my
views but but the people who libel me
including you know some of your
colleagues will not debate you know
because I often said let's debate these
things publicly but they won't debate
them you know it I know that what you do
as a secular activists is to support
religious minorities and what was absent
because it was rookie of feminism was
the the absolute importance of
secularism for religious minorities so
for instance in England where I come
from I've been to meetings where
Bangladeshi minorities have been talking
with with members of the Bangladeshi
Human Rights Commission and the
minorities Commission and so on they
look at looking it's the Hill Tracts
issue as well about the refusal of the
Bangladeshi state to secularize when
they could have they've been caught
judgments it would have allowed a
greater say you know reverting to the
original Constitution and the state the
government hasn't done it and again
Pakistani Christians
who are completely wiped out because if
the Muslim is the other then what is the
Pakistani Christian they do not exist
that other cannot exist because the
other of the other just simply cannot
exist
okay so panelists you have one last say
on all of these questions yes starting I
do think that secularism doesn't mean
you can't practice religion you know
so praying drinking I don't think these
are private practices I'm not sure babe
babe
mark estates being secular or not so I'd
have to disagree with that
I I do think and I and I think if the
Bangladeshi context and of course era is
here and she can talk about this later
but one of the points I was trying to
make in Bangladesh and I'm talking only
about Bangladesh is that the debate on
secularism does talk about religious
minorities it just totally leaves out
others and it has to do with nationalism
and actually my critique is that the way
we've constructed secularism inside
Bangladesh is a very positive obvious
question to is a very nationalist
version of it it's really obsessed with
defining who is really Bengali what is
really Bengali culture and how much of a
distance can you have between Bengali
culture in relation to Islam and
Hinduism and that debate is very very
narrow so for instance restoring the
constitution of 1972 which was in most
respects a wonderful Constitution does
not help the CHT in restoring secularism
doesn't help it because what that you
know because some of the CHT is you know
it's left out what the people in the
Chittagong Hill Tracts want is
recognition as indigenous people you may
agree with it or you may disagree with
it but it's out of the purview of
secularism at the discourse of
secularism so that's why I'm saying that
feminists as feminists you don't need to
expand that discourse I'm not actually
rejecting feminism I'm actually saying
that inside Bangladesh the discussion
needs to get away and in fact my main
sort of the thing that I really attack
is being Galli and
Muslim Bengali nationalism and I think
feminists if they're countering Islamic
extremism also need to counter this very
narrow chauvinist Bengali nationalism
and the two go together they work
together so that's really my argument
more and I think too much of a focus on
Islam is danger in other people's
arguments I think to conflate that I
would say I in fact
Abdullah here name somebody mentioned
him this morning maybe one of the
interesting things in his new book is he
how he argues that for Islam to flourish
in any country the state has to be
secular
especially because Sunni Islam is so
pluralistic if I was talking about how
women under a Muslim laws has these
different you know has deconstructed
with the Sharia is a lot of scholars
have also talked about how the Syrian
Sharia as we know it's a particular
colonial construction but it's very you
know what online argues is that to
protect all thing you know Islamic
practice the freedom to practice Islam
one needs to have a secular state so
that the state isn't constantly
regulating what is Muslim what is not
what you know so and it's it's policing
and that's what sick I mean you know I
subscribe to the idea that secularism is
the management of different religions by
the state it's you know it's government
ality of that's what I would say just
one thing about what what is feminism I
certainly wasn't applying and one of the
reasons I said very specifically that
I'm I'm not saying I'm a Muslim feminist
is I don't want to do this identity
politics and we can have differences in
why should you Azim that you are being
born Hindu and why being born Muslim has
anything to do with it it is if I want
to make it a political issue I don't
want to reduce things to identity
politics and I think that's very
important and there is there are
differences we can we have ideological
differences many of which come from our
location and the fact that I live in the
heart of empire
I understand gives me a particular sort
of take on US imperialism that I mean
when I go back to Bangladesh it's really
not as important for me I also
understand that but that doesn't make it
less important I mean in a certain in
its place
what maybe I should just answer this
question about is there a feminism which
is disinterested I think it's really
difficult to say that there is because
you know if we understand feminism
really as a movement
built on gender identity or women's
experiences of violence or whatever
of course we are leaving out you know
many groups of women and and so you know
we we know that this whatever was called
the feminist feminism or feminist
movement is now divided by race and
class and sexual identities and all that
right so it's hard to say that it's
disinterested feminism has to be
interested and we have to decide where
the interest is right what is our
interest and I think that is the whole
thing is there a universal package that
one can call feminism regardless of
one's particular identity with the
panelists agree with that formulation
yes but we mean by gender right and so
unfortunately the notion of both women
and women in Pakistan - and in the
Muslim world is very very a problem all
right
it doesn't include many women or
majority of women in the Muslim world so
I think that is itself a problem right
because we know that movements for
unveiling
Slama clothes and all has been met by
liberal feminists led by elite women and
I'm not saying that that's doesn't that
responds to the interest of a little you
know women and we have to see what other
interests you know how other women want
to express the interest so that's
something you know that's why I think it
is a problem it has so a fee are you
last last one yet very quickly I just
want to make sure that some of the
questions which were put to the panel
okay if you can take that one up and I
understood vasya and Vienna's question
to be why is it that we are so selective
about which categories we go after so
we're you know maybe we do but at least
in this panel we're not going after
Marxism for instance we're not going
after others why is it that secularism
carries a particular burden that it is
attacked in this dichotomized yes in
this dichotomized
argument but we are comfortable with
taking on board other concepts other
ideologies that might equally be
considered tarnished by the Western
colonial occupation and why just this
one so following that I now have another
amendment I think we should congregate
at 450 rather than 440 because this
conversations been going on a little
long okay first I just respond to for
this question about the nuance I you
know I think please be no answer there's
you know no objection or question of
that all one is suggesting is that
simultaneously I think there is a need
to examine the deeper politics that the
product lends itself to and I think that
you know to say that we can escape from
identity politics you know I hope not
because if we're saying at the same time
that we have gendered identities and we
have you know religious and secular
identity is existing at the same and via
minorities as well how do we get away
from that I mean that what I'm
suggesting is that there could be
perhaps another way to contest out that
identity politics without collapsing
or as Johnny key is saying reducing you
know sort of making it an attack on the
concept of secularism are only
conflating it with one particular
territorial geographical entity rather
than a broad one and therefore not
recognizing the local indigenous native
kind of everyday routine expressions or
articulations of that why do we refuse
to recognize and categorize that as
secular because if a working class
movement is secular nobody attacks that
because it's just politically incorrect
to do so so you know I mean we have to
look at those women also who conduct
their daily routine and lives and which
are mundane and unexcited but which can
be categorized as secular so men are
very happy to attack it for different
identity reasons but perhaps it's on the
question on on laws I'm not going to get
too much into the specifics the sexual
harassment bill has been passed and
implemented the domestic violence law
was interesting because the Islam is the
jamaat-e-islami women were in Parliament
when it was when was passed and they
supported the the bill but the one the
place they got stuck was on the issue of
wife beating and their Samira rkczi on
a parliamentary record has discussed
that you know it's not desirable but
under circumstances certain
circumstances certain women could be
lightly we know whatever so it got stuck
on that but what I'm saying is that that
these are real debates and these are
real identity issues that come up in
Parliament this issue of agency I mean
of course they have agency of course
Muslim women have agency not only are
they you know in mosques they in
Parliament in most of these countries so
let's look at them and let's look at
what they're doing in parliament in the
frontier Parliament they were passing
the husba bill which not only was going
to limit the mobility of women in all
public spaces but it was also going to
such it's while these women were sitting
in Parliament they wanted to pass a law
that said in the future where women will
not be able to participate in politics
and stand for a public office so you
need to look at what they're doing when
they are exercising their agency is what
I'm suggesting was there anything else
Geeta's you know that's interesting when
you talk about how the Sharia was being
discontent
so deconstructed by the women living
under Muslim law program and I think but
what I always urged them to do is to
look more carefully at the doors that
they opened up because they don't want
to revisit then how very adequately and
very you know forcefully the right-wing
women now can engage in that kind of
academic exercise as well and we need to
be honest about the kind of doors we
opened up for it rather than disowning
them and saying that this is this was
not our doing or this is not what we
meant or this is not what we intended it
to be towards that's I think unfair on
the right wing and Salaam is women and
what they they're using the kind of
tools that they're using in the process
thank you all very much I think we
showed that we can in fact agree to
disagree
see you all back in here at 4:45
you